uh continuing our covid quack cures
treatments and whatever uh part of the
show
um I'm going to play a clip for you
unfortunately if someone that was taken
kind of seriously by some early in the
pandemic there is a vac this is a
so-called vaccine expert named Stella
Emanuel and early in the pandemic there
were a bunch of people taking her very
seriously she appeared on the Stu Peters
show this is the guy who thought when he
had a cold not long ago that someone
weaponized a cold and gave it to him he
probably just had covet he's
unvaccinated he brought on Stella
Emanuel
to defend his satanic snake venom
documentary and she says that the world
is filled with demonic clones this is
someone that the right was going to as
an authority on covid earlier in the
pandemic listen to this I saw people
walking on the street and some were
human and somewhere other so we're
demons and the human beings didn't
realize that they were walking around
with demons so right now we are in a
time where I would actually say people
have been cloned and they are walking
among us if you watch the movie called
they leave they leave l-i-v-e it was
created by John Carpenter this is the
world we're living right now and the
only way we're going to survive is if
human beings wake up stop all the crazy
factions the devil has put us in and
stop praying and crying out to God
because that is the only way we're gonna
we're gonna suffer now often with these
folks I come to you and I say this is
not a medical doctor
the crazy thing is
Stella Emanuel is a medical doctor she
is as far as I know she is a physician
and a pastor and she was pushing
hydroxychloroquine absent any evidence
she said social distancing and masks
don't work and all of this different
stuff now as a reminder about Stu Peters
he is this radical right-wing
broadcaster he had the cold or a flu or
covid and he said I'm not going to get
tested but I believe that I was targeted
with this someone injected me with it
this is a very very dangerous guy here's
another clip where Stu Peters speaks to
a guy named Brian artists and they claim
covid is a synthesized form of snake
venom that's the snake venom connection
well what about the name Corona right
does it have a Latin definition or a
definition at all so I actually picked
up what's the definition and on
dictionary.com it brings up 13
definitions Corona religiously
ecclesiastically means gold ribbon at
the base of a a miter uh-oh and I didn't
know what a miter was so I copied it and
pasted it and then hit images
so this actually could read the Pope's
Venom pandemic whoa it also can read
Crown Corona means Crown also in Latin
terms Corona means Crown visually we see
Kings represented with a crown symbol oh
man so put that together for me king
cobra Venom
it actually guys the virus is the Venom
of a king cobra could read King Cobra
Venom pandemic now just as a reminder
artist is a chiropractor he's not an
infectious disease doctor he's not a
medical doctor he's not a virologist
he's a chiropractor and he believes he
has figured it out these people are
dangerous and unfortunately they have
followers very very sad stuff tragic
really
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
I've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when I use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say I'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up I can delete that virtual
card so I know I'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video